cuáles son los signos de seno de menos
210 grados y ccoo secante de menos 210
grados los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y tratan de resolverlo por su
cuenta comencemos dibujar un círculo
unitario ya que tendremos que usar las
definiciones de funciones
trigonométricas de círculo unitario para
resolver esto aquí ya tengo preparado un
círculo unitario que nada más estoy
pegando y que voy a colocar en otra
posición para que se vea mejor una vez
más les recuerdo que por definición el
círculo unitario va a tener un radio de
1 es decir la distancia del vértice a
cualquier punto de la circunferencia va
a valer 1 así que sobre este eje de las
x vamos a tener que este punto de acá va
a tener coordenadas 10 ya que es 1 en el
eje xy 0 en el eje y que por cierto este
es el eje y dibujemos nuestro ángulo
iniciando desde el eje x desde el
vértice sobre el eje x este va a ser el
punto inicial del ángulo que voy a
dibujar pero es menos 210 grados es un
ángulo negativo por lo que va a ir en
sentido horario
e ir hacia acá cuando tengo que recorrer
para llegar a 210 grados bueno sé que si
voy de aquí a acá tendré 90 grados
si voy de aquí a acá tendré 180 grados
cuando necesito para de 180 a llegar a
210 pues voy a necesitar 30 grados así
que voy a agregar aquí más o menos 30
grados y el terminador de mi ángulo
quedará aproximadamente en esta posición
esto de aquí abajo son mis menos 210
grados como encontramos el seno de un
ángulo usando la definición del círculo
unitario bueno recordamos que la
definición nos dice que las coordenadas
del punto de intersección entre el
ángulo y la circunferencia nos darán
tanto el coseno del ángulo como el seno
de dicho ángulo este punto sus
coordenadas nos darán el coseno del
ángulo que en este caso es menos 210
grados
el seno del mismo ángulo menos 210
grados serán las coordenadas de este
punto estas coordenadas van a ser
positivas o negativas la coordenada de
pues está en el lado positivo del eje y
así que esta coordenada y el pse no va a
ser positivo
el seno será positivo
positivo ok ya resolvimos uno de los
signos que nos preguntaban aquí en este
problema
podemos encontrar cuál será el signo de
la cosa que cante de menos 210 grados
bueno recordemos que por definición la
co secante la consecuente del ángulo voy
a escribir más cerca la cosa cante del
ángulo de menos 210 grados es la inversa
del seno del mismo ángulo de menos 210
grados
quedamos que este es un valor positivo
el seno es un valor positivo así que el
inverso de un valor positivo pues va a
ser otro valor positivo por lo que está
con secante también va a ser de valor
positivo así pues tanto el seno de menos
210 grados como la co secante de menos
210 serán positivos